hello I'm Luis Alvarez I'm the head of a
big Hebert's telecom for Mia or Latin
America and i'm here to share with you
what I thing that we can do to involve
more our gem people into both the world
nami phone and the transformation of of
the economy I think that the first thing
they need to know what we are trying to
do here driving the transformation of
our society and our economy for a better
world because this is going to be their
world in the coming years and they have
to participate in this construction of
that new world second thing I think that
we need to ensure that as part of our
communication our programs and I think
that all the plants that we put in place
we benefit from the ambition the
willingness to make a change I have four
kids and they are clearly wanting to
make a change and to make a difference
in the world and what we need is to
facilitate the environment this is our
responsibility making sure that they can
really contribute and pray that is the
main purpose of our work ensuring that
young people are really involved in all
the discussions all the transformation
of all the programs and all the projects
were